[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition du
7 8 journal sur tv 78 voici les titres
de ce mercredi 20 mai alors que les
premières réponses de parcours sub sont
tombés l'académie de versailles organisé
trois master class à destination des
lycéens
objectif assurer la continuité
pédagogique est préparé aussi les élèves
de première à l'oral de français
au programme en juin et depuis le 1er
mai les pompiers des yvelines ont un
nouveau directeur le colonel stéphane
milot a été nommé à la tête du service
départemental d'incendié et de secours
une prise de fonction dans le contexte
particulier de la crise sanitaire
interview à suivre et puis c'est
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale des
abeilles elles n'ont pas chômé pendant
le confinement avec des récoltes de miel
qui pourrait battre des records cette
année elle nous irons prendre le pont
chez un apiculteur à plaisir avant de
développer ces titres la visite de la
ministre des sports cet après-midi opéré
en yvelines roxana maracineanu était au
centre équestre du perray-en-yvelines
échanges avec les dirigeants et
personnels du site visite des lieux au
programme de ce déplacement est
l'occasion de faire le point aussi sur
les mesures sanitaires mises en place
pour permettre la reprise d'activités
équestres
elle nous reviendrons plus largement sur
cette visite dans la prochaine édition
du 7 8 l'hebdo vendredi sûreté des 78
coup d'oeil à présent sur la carte de
bison futé et c'est inhabituel
elle est verte partout en france dans le
sens des départs
à la veille de ce week-end prolongé de
l'ascension période épidémique oblige
les déplacements à plus de 100
kilomètres de son domicile sont pour
rappel interdit et de quoi à privilégier
les destinations régionales nous vous
parlions hier sur ce plateau de
réservation qui ont explosé pour les
gitans vallée de chevreuse est des
domaines ont également rouvert pour
occuper votre week-end c'est le cas du
château de breteuil à choisel le
reportage de mélanie poké et de maryline
iapichino un geste peu attendu en ces
lieux d'histoire mais dans le château de
breteuil aussi le gel hydroalcoolique et
les masques sont primordiaux pour la
visite
les équipes ont aussi revu leur
fonctionnement
nous limitons les départs à 10 personnes
et des gens évoluent librement dans le
parcours du château ce qui est nouveau
ce sont des pupitres dans toutes les
pièces pour indiquer les donnait les
explications les commentaires de la
scène et des objets d'art que les gens
peuvent voir dans cette pièce le château
a ouvert ses grilles le 15 mai dernier
les visiteurs étaient au rendez vous la
fréquentation ressembler à celle d'un
mois de juin normal mille visiteurs ont
foulé les pelouses du domaine le
dimanche 17 mai mettre une semaine dans
les vallées et on a vu qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de châteaux ont posé deux trois
questions nous il était un joueur donc
nous voici ça fait déjà maintenant deux
mois qu'on est confiné à paris donc c
est effectivement assez compliqué à
vivre dès qu'on a eu le début du
déconfinement balle et c'est de faire un
petit week-end elle les deux mois de
fermeture ont bien sûr eu un impact
financier des salariés sont encore en
chômage partiel
les mariages ne pourrait pas reprendre
avant le 18 juillet avril mai juin ce
sont les gros mois pour nous puisque
nous avons entre autres toutes les
sorties scolaires de fin d'année donc
depuis le 15 mars
plus aucun groupe scolaire n'est venu et
ne reviendra pas avant septembre
ces mois de fermeture vont représenter
environ le tiers du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
les équipes ont mis à profit le
confinement pour entretenir le site
après une année 2010 neuf records en
terme de fréquentation
le château de breteuil prend son mal en
patience et nous travaillons à une
réouverture des cinémas début juillet
annonce ce matin du ministre de la
culture frankly esther chez nos
confrères de france télévisions et les
salles de cinéma font partie de ces
lieux vous le savez qui restent fermées
malgré le déconfinement franck riester a
précisé que des mesures sanitaires et de
gestion de flux des spectateurs devront
être mises en place
une décision sur les cinémas sera
dévoilé fin mai début juin
et d'ailleurs pour connaître toutes les
conséquences sur l'activité culturelle
et des sites yvelines ont à 7,8 cultures
spéciales est à revoir sur tv 78 replay
disponible sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile conséquences
économiques de la crise sanitaire
renault envisagerait d'arrêter
définitivement la production automobile
à l' usine de flins sur seine
information du canard enchaîné
le 29 mai le groupe doit dévoiler un
vaste plan de 2 milliards d'euros
d'économies
outre flins trois autres sites devraient
fermer en france l'état prévoit de
garantir un prêt bancaire de 5 milliards
d'euros pour le constructeur
l'usiné de flins emploie actuellement
2600 personnes et a semblé 160 mille
véhicules en 2019
le site produit notamment le véhicule
électrique zoé et la nissan micra
l'école formant en alternance aux
métiers de l'industrie d'aujourd'hui et
de demain le cf ci basée à montigny le
bretonneux a dû s'organiser pour assurer
la continuité pédagogique pendant le
confinement l'établissement a mis en
place un enseignement à distance qui le
souhaitent poursuivre également à la
rentrée au réduiront ce fait le point
avec michael etienne responsable du pôle
formation
pendant les périodes écoles tous les
jeunes ont été mis en enseignement à
distance
ça a été possible de le faire pour une
raison assez simple c'est qu'on avait
déjà entamé l'enseignement à distance
avant cette période de confinement liés
aux qu'ovide les jeunes qui étaient en
entreprise eux continuent à les
entreprises sauf si les entreprises les
ont mis en chômage partiel
mais même s'ils étaient en chômage
partiel il avait quand même la
possibilité sur les périodes d'école de
suivre l'enseignement à distance à
partir de chez eux
comme on avait du matériel dans l'école
on a prêté du matériel aux jeunes juste
avant la période de confinement
la période déjà les dires de
d'enseignement à distance pendant le
confinement s'est très bien déroulé
c'est à dire qu'on a eu un taux de
décrocheurs qui était au maximum à 5 %
et en fait qui n'est pas supérieur au
nombre de jeunes qui décrochent
lorsqu'on a des cours en présentiel
donc on a maintenu le dispositif
d'enseignement à distance jusqu'à la fin
de l'année scolaire
la seule chose que l'on a fait c'est
qu'on a des étudiants notamment en
master en robotique pour qui il était
impératif de pouvoir terminer leurs
projets sur cette fin d'année pour ces
jeunes
on a mis en place par des petits groupes
de six personnes la possibilité de
réserver labaude robotique deux jours
par semaine pendant trois semaines et
cela sur la période de fin juin
on a de nouveau sollicité fortement les
entreprises pour recruter des jeunes et
on a mis en place un job dating virtuel
à la place de celui qu'on aurait mis en
présentiel
on mettra cette opération sur la période
du 25 juin au vu de la réussite de
l'enseignement à distance pendant cette
période de confinement comment on va
prolonger de façon à ce moment-là plus
structuré et plus organisationnel
l'enseignement à distance donc
actuellement on est en train d'étudier
ce qu'on appelle les plans de formation
où on revoit la proportion
d'enseignement à distance et
d'enseignement présentiel qui sera mis
en place à partir de la rentrée afin
d'assurer la continuité pédagogique
l'académie de versailles a mise en place
de son côté des master class à
destination des élèves de lycée
plusieurs thématiques ont été abordées
comme l'économie de la crise du
coronavirus ou encore l'oral de français
pour les élèves de première à un format
en ligne qui a rencontré un franc succès
au rayon
même si les lycées restent fermés les
élèves eux continuent d'étudier par
internet pour étoffer l'offre
pédagogique en ligne
l'académie de versailles a mis en place
plusieurs master class avec des
intervenants de grande école
la première thématique était dédié le 13
mai dernier à l'oral du bac de français
deux jeunes qui planche comme une
émission télévision si vous voulez avec
des enseignants qui les assistent qui
les accompagnent et puis 500 élèves
derrière derrière leur écran qui
s'identifient à ces jeunes qui sont en
train de travailler sur l'euro l'eur
orac la deuxième master class avec yann
algan donc un économiste au sujet du coc
vides et des incidences économiques du
coville a réuni plus de 1000 personnes
on était complet le choc du courant
navires us ne t'arrête pas là l'offre
retenue a été affectée autres
thématiques abordées l'épreuve du grand
oral qui sera au programme du
baccalauréat l'année prochaine au total
trois masters classes ont été proposés
aux élèves de l'académie
un dispositif qui devrait perdurer je
crois vraiment que ces formats gagnerait
à partir de la rentrée à être développé
en faire pourquoi pas une fois par mois
avec vraiment des grands témoins et ce
travail préparatoire des enseignants des
élèves et de ses grands témoins ensemble
prochain rendez vous virtuel organisé
par l'académie de versailles le 26 mai
pour la remise des prix nombreux
harcèlements le point sur l'épidémie de
lakovic 19 dans les yvelines aux
derniers chiffres publiés mardi soir 469
personnes ont succombé au virus dans les
hôpitaux du département trois décès
supplémentaires en 24 heures 632
patients étaient hospitalisés sur le
territoire soit une légère hausse par
rapport à lundi
47 places en réanimation et puis 1788
personnes sont désormais guéri du
coronavirus dans les yvelines après un
passage à l'hôpital dans cette crise
sanitaire les services de secours sont
bien sûr très engagées notamment les
pompiers des yvelines qui ont depuis le
1er mai un nouveau directeur le colonel
stéphane milot qui est avec nous bonsoir
directeur départemental des services
d'incendié et de secours et et chef de
corps des sapeurs pompiers des yvelines
racontez-nous déjà votre prise de
fonction qui forcément a dû être un peu
particulière dans besson dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire
effectivement le contexte est un peu
particulier néanmoins les symboles de
l'installation du nouveau chef de corps
ont été bons étaient respectées les
autorités que ce soit le préfet le
président du conseil d'administration du
10 où le président du conseil
départemental m'ont accueilli et nous
avons dès le 4 mai procédé très
symboliquement et à huis clos à une
levée des couleurs et un dépôt de gerbe
en l'honneur de l'ensemble des sapeurs
pompiers des yvelines décédé en service
commandé
alors vous avez exercé dans le
département de l'essonne des yvelines on
va y revenir juste dans un instant mais
aussi dans l'aveyron et en
seine-et-marne où vous avez été pendant
cinq ans le directeur adjoint du ce dix
ans le service départemental d'incendié
et de secours
comment vous abordez cette
nouvelle mission dans quel état d'esprit
l'abordez-vous d'abord une immense joie
un état d'esprit très positif malgré
évidemment le contexte
et puis c'est pour moi un vrai challenge
de revenir sur un territoire attractif
où j'ai passé quasiment déjà 10 ans dans
de différentes affectations donc un état
d'esprit très positif et une énorme
envie de continuer à faire progresser le
dise j'allais vous demander justement
s'il y avait un engouement particulier
pour voir venir sur ce territoire des
yvelines où vous avez déjà exercé comme
chef chef du centre de secours principal
de versailles chef d'état-major du sdiss
des yvelines également et est aussi chef
du groupement territorial ouest du
département
est ce qu'il ya un engouement
particulier où il ya à revenir sur ce
territoire
oui oui bien sûr c'est un territoire
territoire illinois et les elvinois son
sont à la fois les gens très chaleureux
et puis le territoire est très attractif
de nombreux enjeux dans le domaine de la
sécurité civile et des services
d'incendié et de secours donc
effectivement mon affectation qui était
une candidature donc un acte délibéré de
ma paraît effectivement motivée par
beaucoup d'affect même si même si j'ai
conscience de des responsabilités qui
aujourd'hui sur moi
quel objectif vous vous êtes fixé à la
tête du sdiss des yvelines à la voir
continuer l'action telle qualité engagée
par par mes prédécesseurs sous
l'autorité d'alexandre joly le président
du conseil d'administration du 10
d'abord une comptine une continuité
importante et puis une adaptation
12/10 aux nouveaux enjeux et c'est le
christ de kobe de nous montre un certain
nombre de nouveaux enjeux auxquels ne se
dise doit faire face on l'a dit en
arrivent et forcément dans ce contexte
particulier du coup on arrive virus de
cette crise sanitaire
quel est l'engagement comment sont
engagés ces sapeurs pompiers des
yvelines dans cette crise on imagine
pleinement pleinement engagé dans cette
crise sanitaire
alors effectivement vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui le secours d'urgence à
personne représente presque 90% de
l'activité quotidienne des sapeurs
pompiers tout au long de l'année
cette crise déco vide a évidemment
mobilisé les sapeurs-pompiers pleinement
avec nos moyens secouriste nos véhicules
de secours aux victimes mais aussi une
autre chaîne médicale avec nos
infirmiers et mon médecin sapeur pompier
dans la prise en charge des cas suspects
parce que parce que quand nous
intervenons nous ne savons pas
réellement si les gens ont commis ou
simplement des symptômes qui on
rassemble et nous avons dû prendre
l'ensemble des précautions nécessaires
pour protéger notre personnel avec aussi
les autres interventions qui ne s'arrête
pas pour autant on l'a vu cette semaine
32 pompiers des yvelines qui sont
intervenus lors d'un incendie à
sartrouville il ya aussi le week end du
8 mai où beaucoup d'interventions sont
survenus ensuite aux intempéries il faut
tout de même continué malgré ces crises
sanitaires les autres interventions à
côté bien sûr le même même pendant un
profit demande autres interventions
même si elles ont baissé étaient
présentes le spectre opérationnelle des
sapeurs pompiers qui est très large que
ce soit évidemment le secours de chance
à personne mais aussi les accidents de
la route les incendies tout ça continue
à notre mission de secours
dans lequel on doit en permanence
adapter et notre organisation nous ont
permis de résister et d'être résilient à
cette crise qui même aujourd'hui encore
même si l'intensité a diminué nécessite
un certain manque de moyens d'aider sa
part confié l'organisation de vos
services justement est-ce qu'on peut la
rappeler combien de sapeurs-pompiers
sont engagés dans le département des
yvelines alors on sait qu'il est des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels et aussi
volontaire combien de de force
comptez-vous dans les yvelines
alors je suis 78 à je fais un chiffre
rond quatre mille 4000 agents des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels des
sapeurs pompiers volontaires
et je n'oublie pas les personnels
administratifs qui nous permettent aussi
de fonctionner dans de nombreux domaines
voilà c'est 4000 agents au service du
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours qui avec un des effectifs de
garde toute la journée assure la
distribution des secours sur département
une dernière organisation ont fouillé
une intégration
non mais je vous en prie allez-y allez-y
le service départemental d'incendié et
de secours est un établissement public
qui est placée sous turcot mandement
opérationnelle du préfet mais qui est
financé par les collectivités locales
que sont le département et les communes
un dernier mot pour terminer sur cette
crise sanitaire avec aussi des pompiers
qui ont payé leur tribut dans cette
période début avril nous apprenions la
mort d'olivier lugan pompier volontaire
des yvelines décédé du coronavirus
l'épidémie n'a pas épargné les sapeurs
pompiers n'ont effectivement comme comme
l'instar de la population mais en plus
dans notre exposition au virus
nous avons eu un certain nombre de
sapeurs pompiers et hospitalisée notre
infirmiers olivet ligue ans qui est
décédé à lui contracté le virus dans son
activité libérale parce qu'il était
infirmier volontaire non pas l'ensemble
à elle n'a pas contracté dans le cas de
son activité de sapeur pompier néanmoins
toute la communauté des sapeurs pompiers
est très solidaire avec aujourd'hui
encore sa famille pour l'aider dans un
certain nombre de démarches et puis dans
cette période très particulière
évidemment merci colonel mulot d'avoir
été avec nous
merci à vous et je rappelle que le tout
nouveau directeur des services
d'incendié et de secours des yvelines 2
millions d'euros supplémentaires face au
contexte sanitaire actuelle le
département des yvelines a débloqué
cette enveloppe pour le dispositif
yvelines étudiants seniors
il vise à rompre l'isolément des
personnes âgées sur le territoire par le
biais de visites d'étudiants à leur
domicile pendant l'été cinq mille
personnes contre 1500 habituellement
seront concernées par l'action de juin à
septembre prochain il faut bien vivre
avec une maladie psychique c'est le
thème du concours vidéo de l'association
art convergence basée dans les yvelines
troisième édition de ce prix vidéo
ouvert à tous dont l'appel à projets a
été lancé le principe produire une vidéo
de quatre minutes maximum documentaires
reportages fictions ou encore film
d'animation qui évoque la maladie
psychique
l'objectif est que les participants
s'approprie le sujet et l'intègre un
processus créatif et les vidéos seront
départagés par un jury et varié composé
notamment de professionnels médical et
de l'audiovisuel
un grand prix un prix du jury ou un
autre du public seront remis notamment
avec des dotations allant jusqu'à 5000
euros l'oranje du pain et la présidente
d'art convergence c'est pas une campagne
sans savoir que l'association avait été
créée pour aider directement à travers
les croisières artistique très
qualitatif dès le départ on a commencé
par faire parler les petits groupes de
personnes dans les talents artistiques
des envies artistiques avec les artistes
connus et les pertes par et les sous
types de sucre et on a eu des idées on a
eu une vidéo et qui a été un déclic
parce que c'était un très performant et
cette vidéo a été l'ex 39 les bleus
d'avoir un globe
artistiques et des souvenirs mais n'est
pas forcément utiliser cette dernière
s'est dit que finalement monté un appel
à projets ça permettait d'élargir
[Musique]
concernés d'abord par le restitution
parce que la vidéo c'est quelque chose
qui maintenait les très facilement
c'est à la fois beaucoup moins cher à
produire s il a acculé et les personnes
qui parti comme il ya beaucoup plus de
chevaux en a tous été très intense est
les participants ont jusqu'au 1er
octobre pour envoyer leur dossier
d'inscription et leurs vidéos pour ce
week-end de l'ascension peut être avez
vous envie de vous détendre avec un soin
du corps ou pourquoi pas un ammann en
cette période angoissante
c'est ce que propose cet institut de
beauté à elancourt seulement alors que
toutes les précautions sont prises
les clients peine à franchir les portes
de l'institut marylène yapi chinois cet
institut de beauté qui a la
particularité de proposer également
hammam a rouvert ses portes le 12 mai
après deux mois de fermeture de moi
blanc en termes de chiffre d'affaires
mais pas concernant le travail après
avoir réglé l'aspect administratif et
les nombreuses procédures pour les aides
des reports de charges
le couple de gérants à rénover ses
locaux cette période 2 avril mais il une
des plus importantes de l'année pour
leur activité chez la préparation des
mariages et les enterrements de vie de
jeune fille sont des moments importants
pour nous puisqu'on a des groupes de dix
à quinze personnes qui venaient en même
temps jusqu'à aujourd'hui
actuellement l'entreprise n'effectue que
20% de son chiffre d'affaires habituel
alors pour rassurer les clients une
charte est mise en place
en suivant les recommandations du
ministère du travail afficher dans
l'institut est envoyé par mail à la
clientèle fidèle
il explique que ce qu'on leur demande de
faire et on explique sur le point sur
lequel on s'engage ce qu'on leur demande
de faire au préalable avant de venir
c'est de prendre des rendez-vous le port
du masque est aussi obligatoire
excepté dans le hammam où seule une
personne par salle est acceptée de son
côté l'équipe porte elle aussi un masque
et une visière en plus pour les soins
les cabinets salles sont désinfectés
entre chaque client
les magazines à disposition sont retirés
et le thé ne peut plus être offerts on
est positif et on avance on a fait tout
ce qu'il faut pour remettre à eau propre
ici et tout est quasiment neuf le
plafond a été refaite
tout a été refait tout est bien partout
mais maintenant il faut que les clients
reviennent les gérants espèrent pouvoir
faire revenir leurs salariés aujourd'hui
en chômage partiel petit à petit avec la
reprise d'activité partenaire des boks
cadeau il se montre patient et attendre
que ses clients des tendeurs de boxe
près de rendez vous pour venir se
détendre pour conclure ce journal c'est
aujourd'hui la journée mondiale des
abeilles un événement créé par les
nations unies pour sensibiliser à
l'importance de cet insecte dont le
nombre des clean mais avec le
confinement les abeilles ont pu
travailler plus sereinement résultats la
récolte 2020 devrait être de très bonne
facture le reportage à plaisir de
patrick jacques de dixmude et de mélanie
poké pas de chômage partiel pour les
abeilles les butineuses ont été à pied
d'oeuvre ces dernières semaines de bonne
augure pour la récolte avec le
confinement les abeilles noires ont
profité d'un quotidien simplifiée mais
pas seulement
nous sommes sur une année 2020 qui est
globalement exceptionnelle sur le plan
météorologique nos abeilles ont eu cette
chance magistrale de pouvoir butiner
depuis début mars jusqu'à je ne sais pas
encore jusqu'à quel moment mais c'est
une année d'exception en termes de
capacités donc de stockage domial de
stockage de nectar à plaisir 25 rue chez
berges près d'un million d'insectes ses
abeilles sont protégés par une confrérie
qui fait tout juste sa première année de
création
six personnes la composent on a dans
l'idée de défendre l'environnement et
les abeilles mais surtout l'abeille
noire et il ya très peu de confréries en
france on n'est pas forcément
apiculteurs puisque le but de la
confrérie ou 6 et d'échanger avec
d'autres confréries et de connaître et
de faire connaître les produits du
terroir donc on peut faire venir des
cuisines
despatie chez tous les gens qui
travaillent autour du miel de récolte
sont organisées par an aux alentours du
mois de mai et à la fin du mois de
juillet à plaisir les abeilles ont déjà
donné 20 kg de miel
les apiculteurs attendent plus du doubs
pour la deuxième collecte
nous n'achèterons
nous protégerons est bon c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi très
belle soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]